y todos los científicos...
(Risas)
Sí, todos los científicos siempre ríen cuando digo eso
porque las investigaciones jamás van bien.
Es tan difícil, uno siempre se está arrancando el cabello
tratando de proponer una idea extraordinaria.
pero me di cuenta de que la elaboración de la propuesta iba bien
puesto que podía concentrarme y mantener mi atención
por más tiempo que antes.
Mi memoria a largo plazo era lo que estaba estudiando en mi propio laboratorio
parecía estar mejor en mí.
Y fue cuando uní las piezas.
Tal vez todo el ejercicio que incluí y agregué a mi vida
estaba cambiando mi mente,
quizás hice un experimento en mí sin darme cuenta.
Como neurocientífica curiosa,
me dirigí a ver los estudios para saber qué es lo que sabíamos al respecto
de los efectos del ejercicio en el cerebro.
Encontré una fascinante y gran cantidad de estudios
que esencialmente mostraban todo lo que yo notaba en mí.
Mejora de ánimo, más energía, mejora en la memoria y mayor atención.
Entre más aprendía,
más me daba cuenta de que el ejercicio era importante.
Eventualmente, esto me dirigió a tomar una importante decisión
a cambiar completamente el enfoque de mi investigación
Ahora, después de varios años de enfocarme en esta pregunta,
he llegado a la siguiente conclusión:
El ejercicio es la actividad más transformadora
que uno puede hacer hoy por su cerebro,
por las siguientes tres razones.
Número uno: tiene efectos inmediatos en el cerebro.
Un solo ejercicio que uno realiza
aumentará inmediatamente los niveles de neurotransmisores,
como la dopamina, serotonina, y noradrenalina.
Esto incrementa el estado de ánimo justo después del ejercicio,
justo lo que yo estaba sintiendo.
Mi equipo mostró que tan solo un ejercicio
puede mejorar tu habilidad de adaptación y concentración,
y esa mejora en la concentración durará por lo menos dos horas.
Finalmente los estudios mostraron
que un solo ejercicio mejorará tu tiempo de reacción
lo que significa que
tu serás la persona más rápida al recoger esa bebida de Starbucks
que cae de la barra,
lo cual es muy... muy importante.
(Risas)
Estos efectos inmediatos son efímeros, te ayudan al instante.
Deben hacer lo que hice yo,
cambiar el régimen de ejercicio, incrementar la función cardiorrespiratoria
para obtener los efectos a largo plazo.
Estos efectos son a largo plazo
debido a que el ejercicio cambia la anatomía del cerebro,
su psicología y función.
Vamos a empezar con mi área favorita del cerebro: el hipocampo.
El hipocampo...
de hecho el ejercicio produce nuevas neuronas
estas células en el hipocampo que ciertamente incrementan su volumen
así como mejoran la memoria a largo plazo
y eso nos incluye a Uds. y a mí.
Número dos: el estudio más común en la neurociencia,
observa los efectos del ejercicio a largo plazo,
depende de la mejora en la atención o de la corteza prefrontal.
No solo tendrán mejor concentración y atención
sino que el volumen del hipocampo también aumentará.
Por último, no solo habrá efectos directos en el estado de ánimo con el ejercicio
estos durarán durante largo tiempo.
Obtienen incrementos duraderos en los neurotransmisores del buen ánimo.
Realmente la cosa más transformadora que logra el ejercicio
son los efectos en el cerebro.
Pueden ver al cerebro como un músculo,
entre más lo ejerciten
más grande y fuerte el hipocampo y la corteza prefrontal se volverán.
¿Por qué es importante?
Porque la corteza prefrontal y el hipocampo
son las dos áreas más susceptibles a enfermedades neurodegenerativas
y a un declive normal cognitivo debido al envejecimiento.
Al aumentar el ejercicio durante sus vidas
no solo previenen la demencia o el Alzheimer
sino que crearán
los hipocampos y cortezas prefrontales más fuertes y grandes.
De hecho, les toma más tiempo surgir a estas enfermedades.
Pueden ver al ejercicio
como un plan de retiro para el cerebro
y es aún mejor, ya que es gratis.
Este es el momento en la charla en el que todos dicen...
"Esto suena muy interesante, Wendy
pero yo solo quiero saber una cosa.
Y es que me digas cuál es la cantidad mínima de ejercicio
que necesito para obtener todos esos cambios".
(Risas)
Les diré la respuesta a esa pregunta:
Primero, buenas noticias: no necesitan convertirse en triatleta.
La regla de oro es hacer ejercicio tres a cuatro veces a la semana,
rutinas de ejercicios de mínimo 30 minutos
y agregar ejercicio aeróbico.
Esto es, aumentar el ritmo cardíaco.
La buena noticia es que no se requiere ir al gimnasio
a obtener una membresía muy costosa.
Sumen una vuelta extra alrededor de la cuadra en su caminata.
Si ven escaleras, usen las escaleras.
Usar la aspiradora puede ser tan buen ejercicio de aeróbics como
el que podrían hacer en el gimnasio.
Pasé de pionera en la memoria
a estudiosa del ejercicio.
De lo más recóndito del funcionamiento del cerebro
a intentar comprender cómo el ejercicio puede mejorar los procesos cerebrales
y en este momento mi propósito en el laboratorio
es ir más allá de la regla de oro que les acabo de dar;
30 minutos, de 3 a 4 veces a la semana.
Quiero entender la prescripción optima de ejercicio
para ti, a tu edad, y de acuerdo a tu condición física,
a tu historial genético,
para maximizar los efectos del ejercicio en el presente.
además de mejorar tu cerebro y protegerlo de la mejor manera
por el resto de su vida.
Pero, una cosa es hablar del ejercicio, y otra es hacerlo.
Pues bien, voy a invocar mi poder como instructora certificada de ejercicio
para pedirles a todos que se pongan de pie.
(Risas)
Vamos a hacer solo un minuto de ejercicio.
Es "llama y responde", hagan lo que hago, digan lo que digo.
y asegúrense de no golpear al de a lado, ¿está bien?
¡Música!
(Música alegre)
Cinco, seis, siete, ocho; derecha, izquierda, derecha, izquierda.
Y digo: Ahora soy fuerte
Ahora Uds...
Público: Ahora soy fuerte.
Wendy Suzuki: ¡Mujeres! Soy la poderosa mujer maravilla.
¡Quiero escucharlas!
Público: Soy la poderosa mujer maravilla.
WS: Nuevo movimiento, gancho, derecha e izquierda.
Digan: Estoy inspirado ahora.
Público: Estoy inspirado ahora.
WS: Último movimiento, tiro hacia abajo, derecha e izquierda, derecha e izquierda.
Yo digo: ¡Estoy haciéndolo muy bien! Ahora Uds.
Público: ¡Estoy haciéndolo muy bien!
WS: ¡Listo! ¡Bien hecho!
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Los quiero dejar una última idea
y es: incluir el ejercicio en sus vidas
no solo les hará felices
sino que protegerá el cerebro de enfermedades incurables.
De esta forma cambiará la trayectoria de sus vidas
para mejor.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.